what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Spencer Dinwiddie is
a professional NBA player who is
currently playing for the Brooklyn Nets
he was previously selected in the second
round of the NBA Draft after playing at
the University of Colorado in this
conversation we discussed Spencer's
childhood playing multiple sports why he
chose Colorado over Harvard after
getting a 1400 on his SATs what is like
being injured months before the NBA
Draft what the day in the life of an NBA
player is like what he is planning to do
during the tokenization of his NBA
contract why the NBA doesn't like it how
he views the current free speech issues
surrounding China and the NBA especially
because he plays for an owner who is
more involved than others and he finally
settles the greatest of all time debate
between Jordan Kobe and LeBron I really
enjoyed this conversation and I hope you
do as well skirt school want to know who
has the best URL crypto comm that's
right crypto comm their crypto platform
with one goal mother in mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
calm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out tell them pom sent
you download the app or visit crypto
comm pumps got you always everyone to
get into mining and didn't know how
don't worry your boy pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a Playstation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mine
made easy that's right go to coin mine
calm tell them pom sent you and thank me
later
as many of you know crypto investors
store their digital assets on exchanges
or in cold storage for long-term
safekeeping however this strategy
doesn't help them grow their investment
holdings or build overall wealth with
the new block by interest account users
can now securely store their Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly in cryptocurrency
6% is an absurdly high rate it's the
best rate in the industry I highly
suggest you go check out block Viacom /
pump again that's block 5 com / pop to
sign up and start earning crypto today
Anthony Pompano is a partner at Morton
critique digital all opinions expressed
by pump or his guests on this podcast
are solely their opinions and do not
reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang-bang I've got Spencer
in that house man is gonna be fun we're
gonna talk a lot of sports we could talk
some crypto Bitcoin somehow your neutron
we'll get to that in a second and then
you're you're one of the first athletes
to try to tokenize the contract which I
think a lot of you were paying attention
to so thanks for coming to do this thank
you all right background ever most
people know you as an NBA player but you
know you got a life before that so what
did you do before you get them here um I
grew up in Los Angeles California my mom
was a teacher she is a PhD from USC was
professor there for a minute my dad's
I'm in the real estate my brother's a
genius he may be the smartest in the
family you know with the school play
basketball I only play basketball
playing sports - no I play I play
football as well and also skied so you
ski yeah I know right in LA yeah man I
was actually pretty good though that's
crazy
not a great swimmer but I can ski a
little bit alright wait hold on we got
to talk about this recession it high
school no no so so I never went
competitively
well really competitively in football
this game because at high school my dad
made me choose made a decision yeah and
it was more like injury avoid injuries
or more focused yeah well like a little
bit of both he was like you know if you
want to really do this thing cuz you
know I wasn't like highly ranked or
anything and I thought my dad all the
time like I want to be in the NBA I
wanna be in the NBA so he was like well
if you really want to do it then focus
on it and do it you know and and well I
have to credit him obviously for for me
being here of course because if he had a
tour down my dreams at that stage like
there's no way I'd have been here so him
boosting me in that confidence I mean
obviously it required me to give up
football and skiing but you know I'm
here so I don't know too many kids
especially in LA that want to be skiers
so that's a good choice you made it
alright and then you went to Colorado
right yep all right well my final two
choices for college for Colorado and
Harvard I chose Colorado another
basketball decision I want to get pac-12
I was mad about you know feeling a
little bit under recruited and being a
West Coast kid I wanted to I guess have
some vengeance and yep and gaudium yeah
it worked right alright so one of the
things I want to get out of the way
right of ways you got accepted to go to
Harvard you got recruited there so
you're not a dummy right talk a little
bit about how you did academically and
kind of s18 stuff yeah um you know going
into my sophomore year in high school I
was trying to get into like some program
or some program was like recruiting me
so I had to take the SAT I got a 1416
either so that uh carried me through
through high school as a sophomore yeah
I going into my sophomore in high school
and then oh you know now when it came
calling and you know I had like a thing
my GPA was only like the mid threes at
the end of the day cuz I kind of let it
all go to the wayside when I started
really rolling back my wife and I go a
lot too but you know it was good enough
to get into Harvard cuz it SAT and you
know yeah yeah well and part of this the
reason I want to make sure that people
understand this is it's not a surprise
what you're trying to do now because
you're not just a single you know kind
of fascinated person hey I play
basketball there's plenty of people who
do that those usually end up being the
kind of horror stories I think of just I
don't have skills afterwards you got a
lot of options right so a lot of
different things all right so you go to
Colorado and
you tore your ACL I think it was right
yeah ACL
both meniscus is my MCL that was a
January 2014 and then you know I
declared in April
what's address anyway all right because
this is one of the cooler parts of your
whole story is I actually remember when
you tore the ACL I do not remember the
whole story of then that's when you got
drafted I thought the whole year had
gone by but when I was looking about
before we did this I was like wait a
minute you tore it then declared and got
drafted to a second round round okay um
yeah and I mean so we talked about not
being highly ranked and all that stuff
so I go their freshman year have a Sode
year followed up sophomore year have a
really good year we go to the tournament
I was on draft boards you know they
suggest that come back so I was gonna be
like late first every second so you know
the way we were playing we were about
like 15th in the country were rolling
junior was actually phenomenal at the
time only had a couple losses and I was
supposed to be a lottery pick all that
stuff so it was working um unfortunately
I got hurt but you know I mean I just I
know I was ready I want to go sit so
some of its gotta be like mentality wise
you're like I'm ready to go play maybe I
wanna go play against these guys though
was there any piece of it like you're
already hurt it wasn't like hey if I
come back and get hurt again
I just won't get you know there's a
possibility of like falling further and
further attentionally not getting
drafted at some point or was it just it
was more offensive and like hey I want
to go play let's go do this yeah it was
more offensive just uh from from my
mindset right like when I started
attacking recovery and they started
saying like you know I was recovering
well and all those other things that's
when I really was like okay I can really
do this I can really declare you know
prior to that you know I heard all the
doom and gloom stuff cuz I was supposed
to play for a year you know it wasn't
just a CEOs bonuses NMC oh you know
they're over here like hey look you're
Vinicius was pretty like trash so this
this could get kind of dicey like I
don't I don't know exactly what's going
to happen so in the midst of that fear
that's when I was moreso thinking about
coming back to school and trying to you
know at the very least graduate and and
all that all that stuff but you know how
to conversation my mom I think it was
the
morning it might've been the second day
after I got hurt you know I woke up and
I was actually crying and I talked to
her and this this would be a Nike
commercial honestly even though I'm not
with Nike but you know I was talking to
when I was like my like you know like
why this happened like all this stuff
like you know I still wanna go to NBA
and she's like you know like relax and
oh yeah
I'm like what she said what do you want
to do I was like mom I go to leave she's
not know especially what do you want to
do said I wanna go to leave she said
didn't do it just like that I didn't do
it I'm crying you know I'm kind of my
feelings right now I'm what 20 year old
kid I think at the time who just
apparently had his dreams taken away and
so I'm tripping and she's like why why
right why like Rory are you as good as
you think you are then do it it's funny
how mom specifically they know when to
kind of be soft and and you know sharpen
that or dull the edge a little bit but
then the exact opposite
every wasn't raw they're like hey get
your [ __ ] together let's go and that's
the funniest part my dad is always like
on me yeah and in that moment he was
this awful yeah yeah re man like I'm so
sorry you got hurt you gonna be okay mom
was like boy if you don't just do it
like are you good now as I guess she's
like no it's crazy
and so what were you being told going
into the draft in terms of hey you're
hurt you're recovering nicely but was
there an understanding that you could
fall completely out of the draft to the
later round like well no no you very
much knew you're gonna be yeah her
second dream once we kind of cleared the
first couple of hurdles of like
recovering it was like okay he's gonna
be fine we don't know necessarily
whether it's seven months eight months
ten months whatever but we know he's
gonna be fine
then it was more so like okay he's he's
at worst like mid second it was like 45
or so was like like how far they thought
like I was gonna fall and so I was like
if I'm okay with that and I'm gonna
player I think I am and I think I can
play my way into you know better
prospects after I'm already in the
leaked and
let's go yeah what and the difference
between let's call it 45 and top 10 pick
is what money I didn't draw suits like
that yeah because when I came into the
league the minimum was still around like
five or six hundred thousand it wasn't
like 1.5 like it is now so you know a
top ten pick proudly was in the two and
a half three million range and yep my
minimum was probably you know six
hundred thousand something like that so
okay
quite a big difference but you know the
benefit was and obviously in trying to
be optimistic if I have a one or two
year deal and I play well then I get to
you know my next contract quicker
whereas you know a first-round pick is
gonna be four or five years until they
get to their next contract for sure at
what point after the league you know do
you come across Bitcoin crypto
watch-chain like yeah it's just such
like a especially because you did just
do it you know yesterday right so it's
kind of been something that you've been
looking at like how does that happen
so I actually have a friend in finance
okay I'm works at a bank he told me
about it in 2014 oh really he told me
about it yeah right when I got drafted
he was like you need to put some of your
money in big homie I'm like no way right
when I got drafted the problem is I'm
listening to all these horror stories
I'm like I'm a second round Pig I'm only
been illegal war in two years yeah I
can't I can't bro you know um I wish I
had but now he's probably doing his
victory later I don't know he definitely
is so circle back to about 2017
when I get back to the Nets you know I'm
already made or not get back to nuts but
get to the net all right so cuz you went
you got drafted by the Pistons yeah
then Wayne bowls then nets so bulls is
only for a cup of coffee like it was
literally a couple yeah and I was only
at the Bulls for like a hot sake I guess
just there to say hi take a quick
Instagram in this state I think a couple
of snapshots in a Jersey and then I was
going but yeah so basically it's two
years in Detroit behind in three years
in Brooklyn it's pretty much it breaks
down pretty evenly like that got it but
yeah so I already had a little bit of
money in the
you know being in the d-league for that
kind of like Chicago d-league experience
that summer in 2017 kind of you know
looking at other stuff and branching out
and expanding my mind it's like well
shoot I'm out the league like I have to
you know not just you know I mean I have
full faith in comments I was getting
back in but you just kind of take time
to you know expand your mind a little
bit even kind of be a little more
focused on your family and all those
other things and so that's when you know
I came back across it had a couple
conversation with my guy he was I look
do it so I was fortunate enough to catch
you know most of 17 yeah I got the bull
run so that's when it was like what but
at this time I still don't understand
you know I'm just I'm just listening and
so you know he tells me about Bitcoin I
look up a couple of others like top 10
top 25 the reason why I got into Tron
right so no cubic now let's go so it's
like oh the CEO is Justin Sun he's uh
tied to Jack Ma and then so I know about
how you Bob and stuff I'm like he's tied
to Jack Ma yep
and remember at this time we're talking
more like Vegas gambling we're talking
about yeah several thousand dollars like
we're not talking about like it's not
our true investment you know that you're
specula yeah we this is this suspect at
the time so and this is why you know
even though I caught the Bitcoin bull
run it's not like it changed my life
forever it wasn't I'm getting into it
I'm learning about it and so you know
when the board happens in the subsequent
crash you know you start reading about
like how does the market swing this much
beyond the fact it's in its infant
stages I want to know why but then also
even when it does crash why they're
still over 200 billion dollars in here
why are people still in this what does
it truly mean what is the technology
behind it and that's when you start
reading about it that's music
understanding blockchain that's when
you're like oh I understand why bitcoin
is king now you know in terms of like
censorship resistant and all those other
things so you know then it's like wait a
second defy is a real thing like this
can open up a completely new world and
that's when all of this starts to begin
yeah it all start well it there I forget
who said this and I should remember it
because I want to give him credit for it
but they said I came for the money and I
stayed for the money but they're saying
like I came basically from a
capitalistic I wanted to get rich and I
was greedy yeah but then when I learned
what money really was I learned
bitcoin was like that's why I stayed
right and so it the price does bring a
huge influx of people and I get some pay
attention yeah and and that's you know
I'd be lying if I told you that wasn't
part of like my journey in my story it's
just that like you know now once you're
in now what you read about it and all
that other stuff you're like whoa for
sure this is real this is this is
something that's different
what's the general sentiment within the
league of like true like crypto right so
Bitcoin theory I'm like they're like
that type of stuff that we would
consider more the larger cap stuff a
crypto in the league in a lot of ways is
Bitcoin like if you don't cryptocurrency
it's just it's just bit quietly people
don't really understand you know the
difference other than Kobe speaking at
the Tron conference yeah you know here's
the way I look at it is if you go down
the line I could think of a lot of
celebrities athletes musicians etc who
have done a whole variation of them
right now they're getting paid for the
same thing just like the brain alright
so most people are interested in Bitcoin
specifically and is this like hey I
talked to my financial advisor and we're
building a portfolio of assets and like
we got a little bit of Bitcoin in there
or is this more of like a my financial
advisor told me I'm crazy for doing this
but I got some like you know play money
and I'm doing it with the play money not
with the financial advisor kind of money
oh not like so that excuse me that's the
thing when I said now am I like business
managers and stuff like I tell them you
know yeah well well I personally have a
passion for and to me that's
predominantly Bitcoin and real estate so
I'm like hey guys like you know I
understand like where like some of those
stuff is but these are like the two
areas of focus that I really believe in
so like let's yeah let's let's drive
like my capital towards these areas yep
you know I mean so you know obviously
Reza state is not going anywhere
you know if market can go up and down
all that stuff just like any other
market but you know people are gonna
need places to live we're not making any
more land I'm a big believer in it so
you know it's something that you're
interested in sounds like and you
understand yeah right so it's like hey
look I'd rather go to
and because I calculated on some stocks
that I have no clue about like that
actually may be more risky than some
don't understand there you go and so
those are those are two areas that I'm
predominantly focused on besides like
the entrepreneur endeavors but yeah
predominantly just from a personal
perspective real estate Bitcoin so one
of the things that I've had to fortunate
kind of experience to learn from a lot
of these guys is what I'll just call
like personal finance within
professional sports and it's you hear
the horror stories right hey guys go
broke and all that stuff but there's
even I think it's a intersect or
intersection capital you know they made
a list of like the 50 things that
athletes who stay rich made yeah right I
think I heard Patrick O'Shaughnessy
talking about this with one of the guys
and it's things like hey they got rims
that are 22 or less right you know yeah
they wear condoms like like the guy had
this whole list and it and it's a list
of not don't do this it's a list of do
this right and kind of the positive
affirmation and they're like hey here's
the playbook rather than like don't do
this other stuff because by nature
athletes will oh I can't do something
yeah you're not right and so do you feel
like that's a lot of the conversation in
the locker room is around finance
investments entrepreneurs like all that
kind of stuff or is it just more sports
music culture and there's not so much of
the the financing business I would say
over the last well I've only been in the
leave for five years but I would say
even in that five years you've seen more
of a shift in the guys being more open
about finances what they feel about
different markets what they're exploring
you know I mean I think guys are still
very scared about cryptocurrency in
general which is understandable due to
the crash and and them not understanding
like blocked and stuff like that but you
know talking about real estate or
talking about VC which is very in vogue
right now it is definitely popping up in
the lachrymose for sure mm-hmm
is there a competition on who got into
what deal okay I dropped 20 on you last
night in house I got over before you
know not what not that I've heard I mean
maybe there's some but nothing I know
all right and before we get into some of
the tokenized contract stuff like just
walk us through what is a normal day in
season look for you guys
because I don't think people really
understand like how in depth some of
this is that you've got to do in order
to be ready to play really boy um you
know Monday through Sunday like that
doesn't exist during season there's
three different types of days okay
there's practice day okay game day
mm-hmm and then like your light workout
day okay that's it
I didn't hear a rest day yeah okay so
that is your rest day like the light
workout day is your essay that's when
you go in you know maybe you get like an
hour's worth of a lift or some shots and
you know you get a good stretch in and
hit the Sun or something like that and
then you're out in two or three hours or
something like that but that's your rest
day but you know a practice day I mean
you know price don't start at 10:00 you
got to be there by 8:30 to eat you know
then you're gonna have like you're
correct is that you have to do in the
weight room price goes from ten to
twelve thirty then you got you know
12:30 to 1:00 12:30 to 1:15 a lift and
you're gonna do like your treatment
we're gonna take you to 2:30 2:45 and
you know you're gonna have to do your
recovery which is gonna involve like
cold tub and what and I say you you
probably you probably in there from is
it's almost a 9:00 to 5:00 you're in
there from 8:30 to 4:00
you know yeah roughly so and you're not
sitting at a desk right best like this
is this involves running jumping playing
basketball all that all that good stuff
lifting weights like etc so you know
it's a it's a it's a very involved job
like it's a you know it's it's fun
because it's our dreams and so you know
it's it's different in that capacity
from us enjoying it especially like our
reward being the games and being able
competing and do things that we love but
like people thinking that we just kind
of lay in bed all day and then you know
show up in drop 20 and then go home and
kick it like that's that's not it's not
how it is what about game day um game
day so I've been fortunate enough for
the last like year or so with the
Brooklyn Nets they've been pretty light
on shooter rounds but usually you kind
of have this light practice of sorts
called a shoot around you know from 10
to 11:30 or so in the morning and then
you show back up to the gym probably 5
o'clock for 7:30 game
you have one of those kind of light
lifts 20 minutes or so another round of
shooting for about 30 minutes and then
you have another like treatment around
for another 30 minutes so it's about an
hour and a half worth of work that you
put in prior game yeah and then you
played a game and after the game you
know depending upon whether you're
injured or whether you're working on
something specific or if you didn't play
then you have conditioning right so
let's say you normally pay 25 30 minutes
but that night you played 10 they may
make you run on the treadmill for the
other 1520 that you didn't really know
yeah so it's it's pretty involved like
it's not a joke you know if you and
they're kept like data-driven on all
this stuff and really paint oh yeah they
track you know loads and all that stuff
they they have like metrics for their
second spectrum in the in the arenas
like the cameras tracked like how many
miles are ran they approximate that Lowe
based upon like your your force input
into the ground and how you run
specifically is it oh yeah like this
crazy there yeah so when people try to
think that this is just like Oh going on
backyard yeah like it's nothing like
that and so so it's all data analytics
driven like this is a business you know
if the NBA is pulling in bins and I was
in of revenue right and and the asset is
the one driving that that forest and
they're gonna try to know every single
piece they can about that specific
player a specific person just like any
other big business because I remember I
think it was maybe end of maybe was
beginning a preseason this year or maybe
last year something the video James
Harden working out after the game right
it was like hey to do just you know drop
40 points or whatever and then I was in
the gym and it wasn't why he was
stretching right and inside I guess I
never realized how common that is oh
yeah oh yeah no that's a that's that's
not out of the ordinary alright and the
last question on this I just read an
article about a sleep deprivation mm-hmm
and they're basically talking about you
know the NFL has CTE concussions and all
this kind of stuff ten years ago nobody
talked about now has kind of become the
thing that everyone's focused and this
article was like a two-year study where
they were showing like look man these
NBA players are not sleeping what you
think they're not getting eight nine ten
hours of sleep there
you know getting over the game at 11:00
and get on a flight at 12:30 they land
at 2:00 they you know get to the hotel
by 3:00 but when are they sleeping yeah
and that's 482 games two games in like a
220 day period or something like that so
real problem
yeah for sure Walter what if players do
to try to get over that or come on you
got to be a big Napper you know or you
have to just be a guy that is fine with
that you know there are some guys that
are fine with four hours of sleep and
that's they're just one of those highly
functioning people that does that
consistently I myself am NOT that guy I
get cranky I get grumpy all those things
so you know I'm gonna get my nap during
the afternoon got it all right because I
think Kobe used to do the everyday man
or whatever right where you sleep like
an hour and a half then like an hour
than an hour's like some crazy [ __ ] I've
heard all types of crazy Kobe stories so
like that's him oh no the only two
stories I got for you that that just are
seared in my brain is uh he called the
trainer at like 3:30 went trainer went
home after the workout and they came
back at 10:00 or 11:00 it was like damn
Kobe got here early he was like I never
left
oh the Olympics one yeah that was true
and the other one is uh it was Jason
Williams was that a UH at a game the
pregame shoot around and he got there
and Kobe wouldn't leave the court until
Jason Williams left and Jason's like hey
man why'd you why were you there for
long I wouldn't leave until you left
yeah so it's just it's a mid-table night
he's yeah he's wired different like
there's a lot of crazy dudes and the
league in terms of that competitive
nature but like he's next he's he's all
over Instagram now there's like 12 year
old 13 year old daughter's basketball
game being a dead all right so let's get
into tokenizing the contract right let's
fur before we can't talk about what
you're doing let's just go over the
mechanics of how NBA contracts work so
what's the structure like guaranteed
non-guaranteed and then how do most
players get paid is it a per game is it
once a week twice a week you know how
does it actually work from mechanic
standpoint yeah so every contract kind
of follows this this uniform it's called
a uniform player contract right okay you
tend to get paid by monthly so you know
first and 15th
over a 24 month period that can vary you
know some guys can get it as low as like
a six month sometimes you can get
certain advances or whatever and then
sometimes you're gonna have like
different incentives into a contract
whether you you know shoot a certain
percentage or whatever but all those
things are very individual to that
player and so you know the uniform
player contract just has like the
standard protections right in terms of
like the guarantees etc and then you
know you kind of write in anything that
you know disputes those guarantees so
it's a player option or team option or
something like that right but typically
you know if you have you know that set
guaranteed contract and you know whether
it's death disability or injury or
whatever then your your coverage so
that's a you know the biggest difference
between us and like football right we're
like you know once once my contract is
good for that year or two years or
whatever um if I go outside and you hit
my bus like you know my family is at
least gonna be good yep yeah I won't be
[Laughter]
got it and after you sign the contract
right so most players they've got an
agent agent negotiated the contract you
got your bank or whatever right those
contracts are getting paid to you
personally to like an LLC like how do
most players mechanically engage with
the contract are they signing it
personally or is it through some sort of
like legal structure yeah so you you've
been different well you can technically
do it either way right it's as long as
what the nets are paying to is
considered to be you know if it's you or
a pass-through entity right that you
wholly-owned or whatever then it's fine
right yeah it's like you can't send it
to like a corporation that is like split
or something of that nature or like you
and I can't start a company and you say
a contract exactly exactly so that's the
whole big thing about a cyber right as
long as they are paying you then that's
it and that's why then obviously the
buck then stops after that yep got it
all right and so at what point do you
come up with this frankly probably crazy
idea at first that it becomes reality
but you're gonna Koken i's the
contractor what did that mean to you
what was the idea Genesis etc um you
know I've actually been on kind of a
journey of like intellect
property rights brand fan engagement
like all those things in terms of like
recognizing what our power is as the
asset right like if you look at whatever
permutation of this you want to look at
it right whether it's a you know the MBA
or other big brands that you know use
our likeness for whatever it is
typically speaking and and it's a little
bit different with like a Nike obviously
because they have their own brand status
in their own product that they kind of
really push in their bid not coming on
their own regardless of LeBron James but
in the NBA sense right like their broker
you know the fan determines the value
but the players are what bringing the
value they're the asset they are this is
a really important concept yeah you said
this and I've never heard anyone
describe it this way the NBA is a broker
becoming the fans and the player yeah
they're their job is to obviously bring
the fans and the players closer together
make their interactions as seamless and
easy as possible and they do a
phenomenal job of it right like one of
the best things in the world if you look
at it globally I mean we're second to
soccer I believe right now wow I'm like
growing in terms of like I'd not only
NFL brings in like obviously Subramani
revenue because they can have a hundred
thousand plus fans and we can only have
like you know ten to twenty in an arena
but and I was just honey
the growth in like expanding globally
and engaging in those other markets and
bases like I believe MBA is now second
to soccer in terms of its like you know
growth in his projections so that makes
sense so yeah doing doing a phenomenal
job right but at the end of the day the
inherent value is you know the players
or players it's the asset right like if
you drop the Brooklyn Nets logo in the
middle of the street right here like you
know people might stop they might look
they're like oh that's that's weird
right if you drop LeBron James or Kevin
Durant or Kyrie Irving in the middle of
the street right or Spencer you know I
gotta go I get a couple people but you
you know you drop one of those people
out there there's a flock if you tell if
you tell people on social media hey
they're gonna be playing a basketball
game LeBron's gonna play a basketball
game or Katy and play a one-on-one game
in the middle of the street right here
you'll get thousands and down there cops
not to come here the cops out to come
yeah so that's where the value is you
know and so it any asset right has its
own asset class and then that's kind of
the
real genesis of this whole thing you
know and and we just like an apple or
just like a you know whatever other
stock or company or whatever can kind of
set the terms of what they feel their
valuation is obviously people kind of
you know rate them and have a
theoretical value attached to them
because of the the revenue that they
generate and the products that they
build etc and it's much the same way
with us right we have a somewhat of a
value right like when you look at us you
can any and you look at our contracts
you look at you know our endorsement
deals or whatever you say okay he's
roughly in the forty minute right he's
roughly in the fifty million dollar
range or or whatever it is it there
there really is no difference when you
when you look at it in that in that
manner and so as me the company me
Spencer me the asset I can offer
whatever product I want to my fans based
upon whatever I feel my value is yep and
it's and it's on them to determine the
market it's not in the NBA to determine
marks on them right yeah if I offer a BS
product then they won't buy it right I
guess it's it's really that simple it's
kind of the same way like I told you
before if I went to the bank right now
and told them you know everybody kind
knows my contract is I don't know if you
know via in be a rose I can say the
exact number if I go to like right now
park
yeah ballpark in the thirties okay so if
I go to a bank right now say but by the
way I got at us out there from a skier
in LA to 1300 doing all right guys
no but if I go to a bank right now I'm
saying that hey guys I don't buy 100
mndot house there look at me and say
look you're crazy your contract after
you take out taxes and do all this other
stuff there's no way like you'll you
just want the money yeah you want a
money like it's impossible but if I say
I wanna buy a five-minute a house
okay that makes sense you could probably
pay it off in a couple years you know if
you if you so chose or you could carry
the more 30 years if you wanted like it
would completely be up to you yeah and
it's very much the same way like I said
terms for for product that I'm willing
to offer a dispenser Dimity to asset and
other fans will say hey we like those
terms they're favorable or they'll say
no we don't think those terms are
favorable and they won't buy in and then
the asset or the product rather succeeds
or fails based upon that right there it
has nothing to do with the league which
is why you know it was it was so
disappointing to hear okay all right I
said just so those who haven't been
paying attention you basically said all
right I'm gonna be
I think it's the first athlete Titan
when the four major professional sports
tokenize my contract and the mechanism
in which you're gonna do that is you're
gonna play you have a guaranteed
contract Yeah right and so as long as
you don't die you're getting paid right
for the most part the league is gonna
pay a pass-through entity that you have
right by me yeah they're gonna pay you
and then what you do with your money is
up to you bender and what you said to me
was just made it clear as day to me was
they don't tell you what car to buy no
they don't tell you what house to buy
yeah different they don't tell you what
what casino to go gamble at if you want
to do that you can do whatever you want
with your money exactly and what you've
done is you've structured a offering
yeah right that allows fans to enjoy the
product that you are presenting exactly
and your point is whatever the terms of
the that product there the fans are
going to determine whether they agree
with the terms are exactly they're gonna
determine whether it's favorable so if I
if I sit here and say you know what I'm
not gonna give you any interest mm-hmm
if they said cool then that would be on
them right if I say hey I'm gonna give
you a little bit interest or a lot of
interest or i'mma set this variable rate
or I'm gonna say like hey we should do
it this way as long as the fans
determine that the market or that the
product is a desirable desirable yeah
then they'll buy it you know and if I
want to set those terms the way I want
to set those terms then I'm fine with it
clearly because I set the terms right
because I am the company right that all
the personal entity that set those terms
so really that's what that's that's like
I said the most frustrating part about
it because it really has nothing to do
with them me sitting down and saying hey
that's what I want to do was merely out
of courtesy because I view it as
something that can be beneficial if we
partner I've you it is something that if
the NBA wants to be a part of it it
could offer a ton of benefit for them
because every owner in the NBA they want
a hundred percent you know control over
management decisions etc they want all
of that power but they want to 51%
capital control and exposure there's no
way you go to another being here and
tell them that there's no way you sell
49% of the team to a billionaire and
tell them that you can't have any
control you can't do anything you can
like you can't decide what player we get
you can't have one of your guys on the
executive board nothing they don't go
for that or they go for it and they try
to institute some type of takeover later
like that's yeah that's it's just one of
the two ways that's going to happen so
when you announce this you had already
talked to the league or no no so when I
when I had announced it's the very first
time I had talked to the Players
Association yep Players Association was
cool with it and they thought was a good
idea generally a good thing like you
know you're not you're not doing
anything wrong boom and then the
conversation with the league obviously
were scheduled start after the Players
Association we talked about a little bit
well technically they got leaked and so
that's kind of what shifted timelines a
little bit but yeah I mean it was their
reaction the league was not as static
about the no they just said no you know
and then I was like but why and they
were like well you can't give your
contract to fans it's like that's not
what I'm doing
yep and then I was like so why can I do
it they just said no and I was like that
kind of there's very few times in life
where grown men get jello with no
explanation and it's usually when they
were younger yeah so their parents their
teachers like that's that's exactly
that's exactly how it felt it felt like
you know they were trying to be my
father or my or my teacher or something
and it's no because I said no and I'm
just simply sitting there saying why
like if you can explain to me why I
cannot do it if you can explain to me
legally why this is wrong then I will
drop everything right now I promise you
I don't want to go to war with you
you guys are great at what you do I've
loved my time being a partner with the
NBA and playing in the NBA I'm not gonna
try to deliberately cut my career short
or anger you guys to action against me
so if you guys can tell me why I'll stop
but if you guys just gonna stay here and
tell me no like I'm a child and in you
know get on the phone just tell me like
I don't know I don't to put words in
your mouth but would it be fair to
categorize your approaches trying to
create a win/win between well really
it's a win for the fans it's a win for
you it's one for the league it's one for
the team everybody it really aligns
interest in a very unique way and it
sounds like the league's reaction of
just kind of know which could I think
that's what most fans have gotten from
the media right it's just the league's
that know if there's not the explanation
then it kind of leaves everyone asking
like
why don't you guys like this exactly and
that's the thing like if you look at it
right
so the MBA right now the biggest name
that this is gonna be at a premium not
just this year but years going forward
is fan engagement and getting people to
continue to watch TV right because they
signed the historic TV deal but
technically like on TV viewership is
down right interesting okay in terms of
like the message they wanted to hit and
stuff like that now we're still growing
we're still doing great things making a
bunch of money all that good stuff right
but just looking at the TV deal compared
to how people are consuming media
because we've been getting highlights
and small clips here and subscribing to
this over here and doing all these
things so it's not affecting the MBA
necessarily in terms of the total bottom
line but it's affecting some of the TV
companies so they're a little bit upset
about it right so if you can continue to
drive fan engagement it only continues
to help you yep right and this whether
it's personal player fan engagement or
team fan engagement from them being able
to own fractionalized
shares of the team you're getting fans
to feel a part of your global system
your global entity right so there is no
downside for the NBA because the fans
can't see you but they are now more
entrenched in the NBA now okay and then
the other two pieces the fan right
depend upon the offering that you choose
to participate in there may not be much
downside if any right the way we
structured mine was super safe now we
don't know how much the fan can make in
terms of interest we will see like based
upon you know revenue that I can
generate but the protections are there
so it's extremely safe offering skirts
girl want to know who has the best URL
crypto calm that's right
crypto calm there are crypto platform
with one goal mother mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
calm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out tell them pomp
sense you download the app or visit
crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy Pomp's
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a PlayStation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box
you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new futures on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com
tell them pom sent you and thank me
later one more word from our sponsor
blocked by their new interest account
allows you to securely deposit your
Bitcoin or ether at block five and
receive 6% annual interest paid monthly
and cryptocurrency this rate actually
compound so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block 5
comm / pump again block 5 comm / pump to
sign up and start earning interest on
your crypto today and it's very clearly
articulated one of the things as I was
looking more what you're doing yeah like
there's regulatory oversight right in
the sense of you can't just go do this
without anyone paying attention exactly
and part of that regulatory oversight is
transparency clarity of that you know
kind of structure like there's more
thought into this than like you sitting
at home and just being like let me just
fire off a tweet and like 1,000% what
does percent we spent just about 10
months building this you know we we put
it on blockchain for a reason besides
the transparency and also cutting fees
just in terms of like the scalability of
where we're trying to go into a create
an asset class obviously it makes sense
I mean like I said we reg D you know we
we specifically went that way because
and with accredited investors first we
wanted to go reggae plus we wanted to
shrink every token down to a dollar and
and you know make it you know accessible
for everybody what we understood the
complications with that and so you know
we literally took every single like step
that you could possibly take to be as
careful as possible and then when it was
time to package it and take it to the
table and say hey guys we found
something that is not only beneficial
for you guys
we found some is beneficial for the fans
and we
I found something that's beneficial for
the players right which is another point
that you know to touch on there's a way
and when you do things like this that
you can immediately lock money mm-hmm so
you can create it reserves or you can
create trust etc right so you can make
sure that a guy doesn't spend money if
you have a guy that's let's say if
financial five comes doesn't say hey I
have a guy that's he's shown over the
first three years he's not very fiscally
responsible and now he's got a five year
deal let's say it's 50 min or something
right I want a lock 40 of that away
right now
I'll give him 10 he can spend it
whatever but we're gonna lock 40 and
we're gonna make sure that he can only
spend the interest on this 40 for the
next 15 years
mm-hmm you can do that yeah well it goes
back to the kind of principles of defy
or pity going and kind of software and I
call like algorithmic financing or our
beta finances you can code things in
that matter no matter how upset you get
no matter how you know desperate you are
no matter how drunk you get all these do
other things doesn't matter
sock where it has no money is not gonna
listen there you go and and the interest
just kicks it out to you and as you make
interest you get to spend that money but
you know that through hella hot water
unless there's like some catastrophic
event that money is not unlocking and
we're never gonna go broke you are fine
it's kind of like um so people who
listen podcast know my favorite
basketball player growing up was Allen
Iverson okay right you just hit me with
a cross over and you know years I write
and he is actually one of the the
negative side effects of being a
professional athlete right he's gone
broke for all intents and purposes but
the saving grace he has is one of the
contracts he signed a thing with Reebok
where I think it's equity turns 55 it's
gonna unlock you know thirty thirty five
million bucks whatever it is it's a
similar mechanism now we don't know you
know does he have leverage that you know
there's always kind of things that could
have happened but that mechanism of
there is almost like a safety net for
him right where he had money locked away
till a certain time period and it was
far enough out where like he's probably
much more mature now than he was when he
was in his twenties and thirties that
spent happening for a long time you know
Bobby banila but he's still getting paid
by them
20 here it's like yeah yeah and then and
there's it just opens up a completely
different line of flexibility to these
players that can essentially do whatever
they want you know with their money and
can have all these areas to be
responsible and to do different things
you know obviously with mine I'm putting
a lot in in Bitcoin and I'm also putting
some in gold to to kind of show like the
differences between you know quote
unquote digital gold and physical gold
and all that stuff but that's a very
personal thing but yeah like you I feel
like what we created is something that
literally everybody can win and that is
like by far the most disappointing part
about the the note without a reason
because if you said okay this party is
going to get screwed or this is exactly
why we don't want to do it and you're
violating these terms here or something
like that then we would gladly shut it
down yeah it was a more logical kind of
understandable response yeah you'd be
amenable to so one thing that I think is
important for this is for folks who
haven't spent a lot of time this isn't a
new concept right what I've done by that
is I'll throw a couple data points out
so the Green Bay Packers part of the
team is owned by the fans yeah right the
NFL she changed the rules after they did
this because they didn't want everyone
to go do it you then go to something
like I think it's called fan fantex or
something right where you could buy
quote-unquote stock but it wasn't stock
in the contract it was more stock in the
players future earnings and I think
Arian Foster was a huge user of that so
then you go to the Sacramento Kings they
just announced that it's a utility token
kind of a fan loyalty type yeah so you
had kind of previous you know revenue
share or stock based company their teams
or players and now you're starting to
see tokens it sounds to me right and you
haven't said this to me but I'm gonna
throw it out there there may be two sets
of rules that's right of like the teams
and the things that the accrue value to
the league and the owners accenture get
a little bit different treatment than
the players you're looking at me weird
like it maybe we shouldn't be going here
well I mean the the league is known to
do what's best for them at the end of
the day right every every league does
every little right and if I'll protect
the shield the whole thing yeah that's
that's that's you know what a good
broker does man that's what they do
um I mean it's it's crazy to see though
than them say no so adamantly and then
you know the Sacramento Kings launcher
utility token like the next week I was
like wow that's that's interesting folks
I guess really really really interesting
the reason why we didn't do it
similar to fantex are in the area of
foster model two reasons when you IPO on
like near psychic stage I think that
usually get it up and fee so you have to
have a really large contract to do
something like that or you have to have
a basket of players to do it so then I
said we kind of make it work or or be
raising a lot of money right then also
you know it tends to lack liquidity
because what they're trading against you
know our whole idea in terms of creating
this asset class and obviously we all
know the ease of like moving tokens in
the trade ability of tokens and stuff
like that now there is a one-year lockup
because of the you know what credit
investors and you're talking directly
all that but you know we envision a
situation where you know almost akin to
I guess real fantasy sports right you
could trade a Spencer for Kyrie for KD
for a Jared Allen for a you know zon and
Moosa for carrots levert for you know
you could do that and well and you can
almost like so this is getting into kind
of the future of where this can go right
is let's say that we can get over some
of the the speed bumps here in the
short-term fantasy sports gonna be a
real thing right sports betting gonna be
real thing in United States it's already
moving that way I think the promise of
weather security tokens tokenization all
stuff right you know take real estate
there's been plenty people have pitched
oh you could you know go Long's in Soho
short Brooklyn the writer you know vice
versa or whatever and so you can build
these really unique kind of derivative
products and all this kind of stuff what
you're talking about is like today most
fantasy sports is like you're either on
my roster or you're not is that right
and it's a binary thing yeah but maybe
actually what I want to do is I want to
own 20% of your performance this week
right and I want to earn 40% of somebody
else and a shark kind of creating these
different things or literally maybe I
want to go short point point guards this
year because
the league changed the rules and there's
gross points or whatever it is there you
go
again it's all about engagement and and
my guess is you know considering the way
that the league and Adam silver took the
approach of like hey we want 1% of all
the the sports betting they'll figure
out a way to make money on it - for sure
but that's the reason why I'm saying
like I came and sat down at the table
mm-hmm I came to said here's what we're
doing um if you tell me why I can't do
it then I'll stop but if you say like
hey let's you know find a way to do this
right
like I'm here so like they're
open-minded you're being in a bit yeah
like if there's something that you tell
me right now that you're like you know
what we'll let you you know pass go if
we can look over the terms of deals
prior to them going out so we make sure
that you know checks all the boxes and
this and a third I said cool yep right
like at the end of day my goal was to
partner my goal is to make this a
win-win-win so let's let's do it I'm
like I said the the the disappointing
piece was the no with no cause no you
know answer no whatever it was just no
you know but but you're obviously an
extremely bright individual so and just
talking about those aprox I can come
next and those derivatives etc and and
the different niche things that can come
after this it's a whole new world of
business at the NBA can capitalize on
right it's not something that you know
I'm going to be able to do I'm clearly
just defined the class and kind of
showing guys how to set terms for you
know what they feel is beneficial for
them and engaging in their fanbase
there's gonna be a different whole crop
of businesses that are born on top of
this that capitalize on the actual use
of the tokens like even the exchanges
are gonna try to get into this right
you're gonna have the the you know what
are the biggest exchanges - Jim and I
those guys like you're gonna have those
type of people trying to you know trade
these and some capacity when they get to
securities and stuff off of utilities
like it's gonna it's gonna turn to
something completely different
I'll even take it further and say what
happens when I can buy a token that you
offer and then I can exchange at the NBA
store for your Jersey you know right and
there's some sort of price mechanism
that is actually the NBA comes out more
on top right you come out on top and I
get the jersey that I wanted
you know and you sir playing this whole
game and it's like actually yeah like
like there's a world where this all can
exist all right
what's been the the response to a
sentiment from the players in the NBA
knowing that you're kind of doing this
oh yeah nah see that's the thing
after I after it leaked and after you
know we had some of the stories like the
players have been like yeah how can I do
oh my gosh yeah like how can we how can
we do that and I'm like guys listen like
I'm gonna fight this fight let me be the
pioneers like the whole league it is
exactly like let's let's get through
this and then you know when we get
through this I'll give you guys the
Bible to do it all the information we
gathered I'll pass it and you guys can
do whatever you want cuz I got I imagine
that once they see it's similar to
Bitcoin right once the genie was out of
a bottle and everyone's like you know
they get 3,000 Shokan sorry same thing
here I think is once people realize
here's the potential here's how it works
I guess it is legal from regulatory
standpoint the fans are interested you
know all this kind of stuff everyone's
gonna want to do exactly right exactly
all right we got to talk about an MBA in
China so I will caveat this whole thing
with there's no situation in the world
that is binary black and white there are
no perfect answers so I just want to ask
you some open-ended questions you kind
of run with them as you will first
what's the take from the players in
terms of just like what's going on in
kind of position that you guys have been
put in yeah I would say the toughest
part about being a player in the
situation was just kind of feeling
caught in the middle
mm-hmm that was that was really it yeah
because we you know the uh we being the
nets and the Lakers were there yeah okay
so who I should have started with let me
just for those that don't know Daryl
Morey who's the GM of the Rockets and is
a huge cryptocurrency fan host I don't
know he tweeted out on Twitter saying
just like stand with the people of Hong
Kong it was some kind of a pro or
supportive of the people of Hong Kong
and he was it seemed like at least
externally being more like pro-democracy
right and Pro free speech etc the NBA
had teams in China playing and there was
immediate backlash
really across the world but but
specifically in China and so
when it first breaks what's kind of this
it was it just like oh there's this
thing going on or was it immediate like
he's gonna be a big deal yeah it was
more so like immediately it was gonna be
a big deal especially when it's like the
tweet got deleted and you start hearing
all these different things pop up and
you know for the players because it was
a fight that we were never tried to
either a fight or to be in that's why it
was so awkward yeah and because we were
just kind of in China and we're like so
what do you know what are we supposed to
do come play basketball yeah okay we do
play basketball yep and say hi to the
fans and stuff like that was it was that
simple um so yeah it was it was just
difficult from that standpoint just kind
of just being literally caught in the
middle and it not being something that
we did mm-hmm and then you and your
teammate specifically have kind of a an
additional level of complexity in that
the owner of the nets is one of the
cofounders of Alibaba and I was pretty
impressed he responded right and I was
pretty impressed with the level of
detail that he went through to explain a
perspective that I don't think a lot of
Western Americans understand right so
kind of just how did that kind of play
into it on top of just hey I'm an NBA
player but then like literally I play
for a team that probably understands is
at a different level than all the other
teams in league yeah you know Joseph
phenomenal dude he's uh he's been my
favorite team owner to interact with so
far um that's that's my guy and you know
actually it was an educational process
for art at minimum our team right
because we did have a chance to sit down
and talk to Joe any kind of debriefing
on the situation and the severity and it
was just honest with you know what was
going on and in his personal opinion and
why he wrote you know the letter that he
wrote which we all respected and like I
said we gained not from it and you know
he he really kind of broke down why it
was a you know a sensitive topic for you
know the
to the country yeah and in the part to
me - oh just beforehand I'd like and
this is my personal perspective this is
not Spencer's respect yeah that I felt
was unfair in the whole situation was
the press conferences where players I
didn't see a video of you getting kinda
ambushed but I saw some other players
that they've got to be there right you
know the whole Marshawn Lynch I'm only
here so I don't get fine they're sitting
up there and reporters granted they're
just trying to do their job right so
they're asking questions but the
questions are almost like I know I got
you trapped I know you got a microphone
in front of you and I'm gonna try to
elicit you just say yeah just things
that'll catch headlines do just felt a
little unfair I think to the players
they're sure for sure I mean I was
saying general we find ourselves in
situations like that you know sometimes
and and that's definitely all media you
know media and there's a lot of me that
does a phenomenal job there's a lot of
media that has been great to players a
lot of me that you know enhances you
know the game in the individual and all
that stuff and then you know there are
some instances whether it's you know you
missing something as well as you missing
the game-winning shot or you kind of
being in the middle of some you know
political controversy where they do ask
pointed questions based upon you know
the situation that you're in and try to
elicit that response that you they know
could be negative right you know those
are situations that are unfair but you
know they they happen they happen and
it's on us to be authentic to whatever
it is that we feel in that moment
whether it's to comment or not comment
yeah you know I think that's why you saw
like you know like the Steve Kerr's etc
of the world kind of say look I'm not
well-versed on the topic and I know you
know President had his opinions about
that but you know you're well within
your right to say I don't know yeah
there's nothing wrong with not knowing
everything there's some people who
should be saying I don't know and let's
kind of pull away from China and just
more kind of this you know social impact
and cultural impact that professional
athletes gonna have the thing that I
think a lot of people kind of forget
very easily is the same you know kind of
oh it's uncomfortable as an athlete to
be put in a position where I'm getting
asked questions I don't understand
something you know whatever
a lot of these athletes are still using
that same exact star power etc for
really good things in their communities
and in the United States all stuff and I
always go back to the beautiful thing
about the United States is I don't care
if you agree with the person or not yeah
they have the right to do it they have
the freedom to do it and if you look
across the NBA NFL can all these leagues
most of the guys are doing really
positive things yeah exactly
right and they're using it to their
benefit of their communities etc and so
you know it's kind of just I can't take
a deep breath yeah exactly exactly I
think when you look at where a lot of
these guys came from and being able to
succeed at the different levels of
they're able to succeed we all have a
certain level of you know indebtedness
to where we came from and wanting to you
know have a positive impact on those on
those places and on those people and and
you know the the more that doing good
has become in vogue and become public
and all these things like you know
you're you're just saying more and more
and so the more positive light we can
shed on things in terms instead of
negative just positive energy in general
like it's contagious and it does wonders
for you know everybody that's you know
around it and associated with it for
sure
I usually end up with rapid-fire
questions about cuz I got you here we're
going with some basketball rapid-fire
LeBron Jordan or Kobe who's the goat who
was the goat
I know I know you've debated this pie
for too many hours of your life see I'm
with Oh some of us that you guys I'm not
I'm not even gonna pick it's cuz my
favorite players on bias but I will say
the goat across all different levels the
best was cream abdul-jabbar high school
college pro had to change rules for him
he's the leading scorer in NBA history
ever talking about full career goat
that's him
we just talking I like you know six
years ago prime then it's Jordan cuz he
had two six I know but okay full career
boring okay that's actually pretty good
like legitimate answer yeah they changed
the rules and pretty much it's argue
against what's your favorite NBA playoff
memory favorite NBA playoff memory not
that not you but like a faint like a fan
yeah oh it had to be the tip out to
orange three
that was Big Shot Bob Oh [ __ ] iPod yeah
because I was panicking you know the
little kid that was a that was a super
Laker fan it was
anything at the moment like guys like we
not really shouldn't lose oh come on
that's a pretty good one and then if you
could play with any player in the NBA
today who would it be Kevin Durant ha ha
kick can we get some inside knowledge on
how how this all went down um you know
they had that famous phone call that's
what I said all right they had the
favorite they had the famous phone call
were they gone through a FaceTime it
like 4:00 a.m. and then you know the who
was on it was Katie Katie Harry and DJ
and then I was at 4:00 a.m. through a
FaceTime sighs who deal done I
I gotta admit part of the MBA that did
not exist when I was a kid or when you
were a kid that now has become so kind
of enthralling is I was a couple years
ago when everyone was tweeting the
emojis right who's gonna go you know or
the DeAndre Jordan I think or say like
that I'm not leaving right the phone
calls you know Kawhi Leonard right your
honor people and and it's it it kind of
is more entertaining than some of the
actual basketball developments right how
does all this stuff happen yeah another
MV isn't a great job of like making free
agency a must-see TV event you know and
then keeping us on the minds at a fan's
for you know the full 12 months yeah
absolutely
what's your favorite book my favorite
book actually you know this is gonna
kind of be a little I got 1,400 SAT like
me with some stupid no I'm not gonna hit
was I'm stupid I'm say the Bible because
that's what I'm testing myself with
reading through front to back this year
wow yeah well how far you think you're
no no I'm saying that's what this is
gonna mean like my season tasks it's oh
oh this during the season front to back
that's actually pretty good
yeah not just passages but like yet
start to finish alright you're gonna
come back and we're gonna see if you
finished at the end of the see so we go
I usually let everyone ask me one
question the end but before aliens
believer or non-believer
are they real I'm a believer yeah why
I just I don't know I feel like stuff
that happens just is it's not all
coincidence not just all randomly I feel
like things have purpose of technology
advances quickly like we have all these
ideas and they all keep you know
manifesting in this similar type of like
depiction writing is like y'all thought
about aliens and they all look the same
way how'd that happen
it didn't make any sense to me we
couldn't get a variety of imagination
no it's government propaganda they all
got to be yellow or a green slime you
come down in the dark weird all right
what one question you have for me to
finish this what one question I'm
nervous what you could ask me most
crypto people come and ask me crazy
stuff but you get asking all kinds of
crazy stuff personal question
all right twenty thirty what do you see
Bitcoin in finance in general that's
good cool not not just price prediction
when you see like how are malls like
you'll get the in the compliance
department to come over yeah you know if
I do prices here no so I I think that I
could talk about it for like a trend
standpoint so I think that's the easiest
thing to be right about right some kind
of from a selfish standpoint first I
think a lot about automated finance and
so if you think of every stock bond
currency and commodity being digitized
yeah that unlocks the potential for
automation so we see a little bit of it
today you know Robo advisors is kind of
advising you on how to invest your
capital or we see things like you know
with crypto you can like put your
Bitcoin in and get a US dollar loan than
some of the defies the writer or tokens
dollars etc so I think all that stuff
will become more and more prominent but
it's intersecting with like true
automation so things like plaid except
where you can pull in all of your bank
information I can do a better
underwriting model to give you a loan
like that's how it's done so that's one
- I really do believe that we're gonna
see more and more when I say currencies
fail and these are nation-state
currencies is not like
they failed because somebody like blew
up the country like that type of stuff
right it's more of just throughout
history if you look from literally the
time you know ancient Roman times yeah
the downfall of currencies was debasing
them right and so that's what we're
doing with inflation and QE and all
stuff and so I don't think that that's
like a 50% of the currencies fail by
2030 right I think it's a small
percentage but I think we will continue
to see this and again some small subset
of people will kind of keep putting
capital into Bitcoin at some point the
future I do you think it becomes a
global reserve currency well and it's
because it has the one thing that none
of the other currencies have right so
like I always go back to this idea that
in order to have really really big
innovations normally that happens if
somebody does something different and
they're right yeah so Bitcoin is
definitely doing something different and
then it's a non nation-state back to
currency it's deflationary structure
with a disinflationary monetary supply
and it can't be manipulated because
there's kind of software algorithmically
disciplined those three things are very
very different than every other currency
know so we got to be different down for
sure if it ends up being right changes
the world right and so if you look
around the world why would somebody be
interested in this well if you live in a
country where you're worried about you
know your country or one of the
corporations seizing your assets the
fact it's non seasonable is pretty
important right here in the US like I
don't know about you I'm not worried
about like you know Bank of America
taking settlement now it could happen
happen in cyber you know whatever but
that's just not a dating desert I'm much
more worried about the fluctuation in
price right because the dollar stable
versus that yeah so you just look around
the world like time and time again we
see these little examples pop up
eventually that becomes like it's kind
of like a drum in the background and the
next thing you know it's like the
mainship exactly right so I think
that'll happen and the last thing that I
think is pretty interesting is
white-collar jobs watch be more affected
by the automation than blue-collar jobs
but the advice will become more
important so look at lawyers right like
it was like oh we're just like automate
away the lawyers know what you can do
your automate away like the paper
work pinion and it's gonna become more
important right because now I can't read
the code so if I can't read the code I
really need to make sure somebody can
audit it somebody should I said all that
kind of stuff so again this is stuff you
know you're asking me basically 10 12
years out right type stuff and so it's
generally we're gonna move in that
direction will happen right by 2030 of
course but but I definitely think that
all is like where we're going okay I get
it well yeah yeah come on in terms of
like ease of moving these things around
right yep like wait where do you see
that turning to light wood because
obviously like crypto kitties tanked
etherium right and so now you have all
these other like black teams that are
more scary scalable and whatnot in terms
of like this smart contract basically or
not so much the currency peel of it
right but like where do you see what
what else do you see that can kind of
like move in and do these things that
yeah so there's no one direct answer I
usually answer this time from different
couple different angles take cell phones
right what's up phones first came out
there the big brick things you had to be
pretty wealthy to get one or you got to
be doing much in nefarious [ __ ] the two
types of people had cell phones but you
couldn't call everyone yeah so like if
you were the one friend out of all of
your friends who had a cellphone Dan
yeah well it was it was cool because if
your friend went to a payphone they
could call you or from their house he
could call you and they could get you
cuz you're with your mobile phone but it
wasn't as valuable to you if none of
your other friends hackers you saw the
other house they're not there you know
all stuff so as you got more density in
the cell phone network that cell phones
became more valuable right the other
piece of it is the technology doesn't
necessarily have to be the best has to
be good enough right and so you look at
Betamax vs. DHS you know all these
examples and so when I look at like how
the assets move around today right I
actually fall in the category of yes
there are definitely things that could
be quote unquote better right in terms
of like oh it's not instantaneous in
seconds yeah but if you you know I've
said twice now so one if I want to send
a Bitcoin on the Lightning Network it
will actually settle faster than if I
put a credit card chip into a chip
reader yeah you know when you go to like
a Starbucks on you bill
it's like you know processing approving
whatever like it's pretty fast right
obviously but it's still the light never
can be faster right and then if you look
at sending Bitcoin on the Bitcoin
network versus sending a wire at the
bank the bank takes one day to settle
yeah so let's say that the Bitcoin
changes accent takes ten minutes it's a
pretty material exams right and so it's
all kind of relative but the thing that
becomes most important is it's highly
highly highly secure reserved no
centralized authority yeah and so to me
it if you are the best at the security
and the lack of centralized authority
and you can do it at the time well it
just wouldn't prove overtime right go
back to the internet the dial-up right
like I you're probably you know you're T
once your concert yeah hey oh well like
we used to literally like that was like
the first a my hat right was like all
right I got the 30 day trial how do I
get another 30 day trial so we never had
like we never paid for AOL but we always
had the one who the free trials and so
if you were using the internet you
couldn't use the phone line yeah right
and then like I remember like my mom
would be screaming at get off the
internet they make a phone call right
like today we've got what exactly what
and yeah that was in the mid 90s right
so so we're talking 2025 years max like
that's how far we've come
yeah and so you know look out again 10
15 20 years with Bitcoin like I'm not
saying that it's gonna be you know I
blink and my brain wallet sends a
Bitcoin to a machine it kind of this
super like size of my futuristic but I
am saying that it's gonna be much better
improved user experience better you know
in terms of scalability speed lower fees
all I cus tough but takes time for
people they're looking at it like you
know hey the iPhone yeah
12 year old technology there's a lot of
cell phones before the iPhone yeah right
now it's the same technology though
right so I don't actually think that
somebody's gonna replace Bitcoin I think
that it's just gonna take time for
people to keep building and improving
the bigger technology and eventually
it'll be what everyone wants it to be
but it's good places this is so alright
anything will hold on where can people
go find out about
the contracted kind of what you're doing
with with tokenization dream finishes
calm dream fan chairs calm what was that
where the name come from um so fan
chairs I mean obviously is you know
pretty self-explanatory pretty
self-explanatory um the acronym dream so
the the company that builds my shoes is
called project dream and so you know
when I signed on to do that and got you
know some co-founder equity in and I
just really loved the what they were
kind of doing with the disrupt reality
every available moment like the acronym
disrupt reality every available moment
yeah just the acronym that they were
doing so I was like hey guys um you know
fan shares calm whatever was is taking I
was like hey do you think like I could
borrow acronym there I go for it and I
was like alright cool
yeah just put a link on there awesome it
alright well best of luck with this
we'll definitely make sure that we tweet
it out and everything when it goes live
then good luck with the season and that
when you come back when I see if you got
done reading the Bible if you guys want
NBA championship though you brother
that's good huh hey everyone pop here if
you like this episode of off the chain
and want to help us to take crypto to
the top of the Apple Spotify and other
podcast charts please do us a favor and
rate review and subscribe to review
simply go to the off-the-chain homepage
scroll down until you see the five blank
stars taking 15 seconds to fill those
stars in and leave a quick review goes a
long way in helping us take the entire
crypto ecosystem to the top of the
charts I appreciate you listening and
see you next time on off the chain
you